♪ ♪
>> I AM ANNOUNCING THIS YEAR
WILL BE MY LAST ONE IS A MEMBER
TO BE CLEAR, I'M NOT RESIGNING.
I INTEND TO FULFILL MY TERM AS I
WAS ELECTED TO DO BUT I WILL BE
RETIRING IN JANUARY.
YOU ALL KNOW I DO NOT SEEK THIS
JOB.
I TOOK IT RELUCTANTLY.
BUT I HAVE GIVEN THIS JOB
EVERYTHING THAT I HAVE.
THEN I HAVE NO REGRETS
WHATSOEVER FOR HAVING ACCEPTED
THIS RESPONSIBILITY.
THE TRUTH IS, IT'S EASY FOR YOU
TO TAKE OVER EVERYTHING IN YOUR
LIFE.
I JUST DON'T WANT TO BE ONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE LOOKING BACK
THINKING I SPENT MORE TIME WITH
MY KIDS WHEN I KNOW THAT IF I
SPEND ANOTHER TERM, THEY WILL
ONLY KNOW ME AS A WEEKEND
FATHER.
>> Bret: SPEAKER PAUL RYAN
SAYING HE WILL NOT SEEK
REELECTION.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETING:
"SPEAKER PAUL RYAN IS A TRULY
GOOD MAN, AND WHILE HE WILL NOT
BE SEEKING RE-ELECTION, HE WILL
LEAVE A LEGACY OF ACHIEVEMENT
THAT NOBODY CAN QUESTION.
WE ARE WITH YOU PAUL!"
THE PRESIDENT IS ACTUALLY WITH
PAUL RYAN CURRENTLY.
HAVING DINNER AT THE WHITE HOUSE
ALONG WITH SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER MITCH MCCONNELL, KEVIN
McCARTHY, AND SENATOR JOHN
CORNYN.
AS FAR AS POSSIBLE REPLACEMENTS
WHEN THE SPEAKER DOES STEP DOWN,
YOU'VE GOT KEVIN McCARTHY AND
STEVE SCALISE WHO ARE KIND OF
JOCKEYING OUT FOR POSITION.
POSSIBLY TO BE THE NEXT SPEAKER
OR, IF REPUBLICANS LOSE, THE
NEXT MINORITY LEADER.
LET'S BRING IN THE PANEL.
BYRON YORK,
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER."
A.B. STODDARD, REAL CLEAR
POLITICS.
ELI LAKE, COLUMNIST FROM
BLOOMBERG VIEW.
A.B., HE A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE
SURPRISED BY THE ANNOUNCEMENT
BUT MAYBE NOT SURPRISED HE WAS
GOING TO MAKE THIS MOVE.
>> I THINK A LOT OF REPUBLICANS,
SPEAKER AGAIN.
I THINK A LOT OF REPUBLICANS
ASSUMED PAUL RYAN WAS GOING TO
RUN FOR HIS SEAT, WAKE UP AFTER
ELECTION DAY, COUNT THE LOSSES
AND QUIT.
THAT WOULD BE THE CHEAP THING TO
DO AND IT'S NOT LIKE PAUL RYAN
AND HE COULDN'T STOMACH DOING
THAT.
HIS DISTRICT COMES FIRST.
THE KID THING IS REAL.
WANTING TO BE WITH HIS CHILDREN
WHO HAVE NEVER KNOWN HIM LIVING
AT HOME FULL-TIME ISRAEL.
BUT -- IT'S REAL.
HIS FEALTY TO WHAT WAS THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY CANNOT BE
OVERSTATED.
HE WANTS TO PUT EVERYTHING INTO
AN EFFORT TO MITIGATE THE LOSSES
AN EFFORT TO MITIGATE THE LOSSE
LOSSES.
HE WILL NOT BE UNTETHERED AND HE
WILL NOT BE LIBERATED.
HE WILL NOT BE CRITICIZING THE
PRESIDENT.
HE WILL DO EVERYTHING HE CAN
UNTIL THE LAST HOUR TO MAKE SURE
THEY HOLD THE HOUSE AND KEEP THE
LOSSES TO A MINIMUM.
>> Bret: BYRON, IT'S SEEMING
LIKE IT'S MORE OF AN UPHILL
BATTLE TO DO THAT, HOLD ON TO
THE HOUSE.
YOU HAVE 26 RETIREMENTS, 13
RUNNING FOR OTHER OFFICE, THREE
SEATS ARE VACANT.
NOW YOU ARE AT 41 REPUBLICANS,
INCLUDING NOW THE SPEAKER NOT
RUNNING FOR REELECTION.
AND THE DEMOCRATS NEED TO PICK
UP 25.
IT'S GETTING TOUGHER.
>> THIS IS NOT THE SIGN OF A
PARTY THAT'S WORKING WELL OR
WORKING SMOOTHLY.
EVEN IF YOU PUT THE PRESIDENT'S
TROUBLES ASIDE IN HIS RELATIVELY
LOW APPROVAL RATING, JUST THE
HISTORICAL TRENDS ARE TERRIBLE.
BILL CLINTON LOST 54 SEATS IN
HIS FIRST MIDTERM.
BARACK OBAMA LOST 63 SEATS IN
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN UNDER
GEORGE W. BUSH BECAUSE OF
SEPTEMBER 11TH.
THIS IS NOT LOOKING GOOD FOR
REPUBLICANS NOW.
THE OTHER THING IS IN THE COURSE
OF LESS THAN THREE YEARS, TWO
REPUBLICAN SPEAKERS OF THE HOUSE
OF BALES.
PAY UP AND QUIT.
JOHN BOEHNER DATED IN LATE 2015.
THAT'S HOW WE GOT PAUL RYAN.
I THINK THAT SPEAKS TO THE FACT
THAT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
CONTROL THE FACTION-RIDDEN HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES G.O.P.
CAUCUS.
YOU'VE GOT THE FREEDOM CAUCUS.
YOU'VE GOT THE TUESDAY GROUP.
YOU'VE GOT A BUNCH PEOPLE.
YOU DON'T HAVE A HUGE MAJORITY,
AND IT'S TOUGH TO GET TO GET 218
VOTES.
>> Bret: ELI.
>> YOU LOOK AT THE ELECTION OF
TRUMP AND TO THIS DATE, YOU ARE
SAYING THAT'S THE ARK OF THE
TRANSFORMATION OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
PAUL RYAN IS AN EMBLEM OF A
REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT WAS
AGAINST DEFICITS, WAS FOR LOWER
TAXES, WAS CERTAINLY, THERE'S
ALWAYS A POPULAR APPEAL BUT IT'S
NOT THE SAME KIND OF POPULIST AS
TRUMP.
NOW THE G.O.P. IS REALLY TRUMP'S
PARTY.
THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT THING WHEN
WE TAKE A STEP BACK.
>> Bret: LET'S LISTEN TO THE